hey guys it's video with maxtec and
we've been recently getting some
bombshell leaks for the upcoming macbook
air that we should be expecting later
this year as well as a future even
larger macbook air which is absolutely
mind-blowing i can't believe apple is
actually working on this so what i'm
gonna do in this video is go through all
those new leaks and how the puzzle
pieces come together in terms of the new
leaks compared to the old leaks and when
we should expect a new macbook air what
we should expect to come inside of it
and the new one so let's jump right into
it first of all i want to show you guys
my custom macbook air redesign renders
that i created with renders by shy lash
you can see right here yes it's got a
notch yes it's got white bezels it's got
the white keyboard with the white
keyboard well and of course this new
blue color look at that it looks
absolutely amazing on the bottom we have
that cut out macbook air text the four
feet and of course on the sides we've
got the same design that's kind of
rounded like the new macbook pros but
enough about that let's jump into the
actual rumors and
we just got a report from digitimes
confirming that apple is gonna be
launching the new redesigned macbook air
in the second half of 2022 which means
we should not be seeing it in june after
wwdc event we should not it's gonna be
later on this year and i completely
agree with this and i've been expecting
this for a while because way back last
year in september ming chi kuo said that
he expected the new macbook air redesign
with the next gen m2 chip to arrive in
the third quarter of 2022 yes that is
the fall of this year and that was way
back then so i completely believe in
what mingxiko was saying and i think it
totally lines up with what apple has
done in the past for example releasing
the m1 macbook air in the fall november
of 2020. i think they're gonna do it
again this time around and the craziest
macbook air news that just dropped was
actually from ross young who has 25
years of experience in the display
industry and so far he has been on point
with display leaks in terms of apple
products like the ipad mini and the new
macbook pro displays so i really trust
in what he has to say and he's
apparently saying that we should expect
a new larger 15 inch macbook air in
2023 unfortunately not this year but
actually
next year and getting into the actual
details that he's saying he's saying
that we should expect two new display
sizes however without mini led but
moving on to what he actually has to say
he is saying that the new macbook air
that's coming out this year is gonna
have a display size of 13.6
inches yes that's 0.3 inches larger than
the current macbook air which has a 13.3
inch display and this is actually a very
big deal
because it basically hints at apple
giving the new macbook air
a notch yes i know the leaks have been
very confusing because some people have
said there's no notch and others have
said there will be a notch and i think
this actually confirms that yes there
will be a notch because if we look at
what happened with the macbook pro
specifically the 16 inch model it used
to be exactly 16 inches but with the m1
pro and max chips it jumped up to 16.2
inches so it went up slightly higher
literally because of the notch so i
think this 0.3 inch difference is
because they are gonna give a notch to
this year's redesigned macbook air but
moving on to the 15-inch model he is
saying that the new 15-inch is gonna
have a 15.2 inch display but
unfortunately that is not coming until
next year so let's pivot back and focus
on all the new leaks surrounding this
year's macbook air that we should be
getting later this year now we have a
leak from leaks apple pro who said he
has an exclusive leak that apple is not
going to be launching the new macbook
air any sooner than september which
basically crosses out wwdc in june as a
potential possibility and i personally
completely agree with that but making
this rumor even more solid a few weeks
back mark german decided to host a
twitter spaces of his power on and he
gave us some bombshell leaks he
personally said that we should be
getting new max announced between may
and july
including a new m2 macbook pro 13-inch
basically a replacement for that model
which it might be just called the
macbook and possibly either an m2 imac
or maybe an m2 mac mini so with that
said right after that twitter spaces i
decided to make a little prediction and
theory on apple's future mac lineup and
part of that is going to include the m1
macbook air yes the complete old model
at the same 999
dollar price so they're not going to
scrap it they're going to keep it around
and then they're going to introduce that
new m2 macbook in the summer time or
june and then they're going to release
the m2 macbook air redesign in the fall
and of course the m2 mac mini and the m2
imac before next year moving on to the
pro and pro max models and if you think
it's crazy for apple to keep the same m1
macbook air around for another year i
personally do not because mark german
actually gave us a leak way back last
year
he actually said the new laptop is
destined to be a higher-end version of
the current macbook air which is
expected to remain in the company's
lineup as an entry-level offering so yes
that means the thousand dollar m1
macbook air is gonna stick around now as
far as the actual features and specs
that we should be expecting from the new
redesigned macbook air we should first
and foremost expect the new m2 chip
which is a direct replacement for the m1
and mark german from bloomberg actually
detailed exactly what we should expect
he thinks the m2 is gonna come with an
eight cpu core layout which is exactly
what we already have in the m1 so for
performance and four efficiency cores
but they're just gonna be bigger and
better cores with newer technology
potentially newer media engines maybe
other stuff added in like neural engines
but as far as the graphics scores it's
gonna be jumping from seven or eight to
nine or ten graphic scores so just two
extra graphics cores which is gonna
improve the graphics performance and as
you can see with these charts that's the
performance jump we should be expecting
if apple bases it off of the a16 which
actually isn't out yet but it will be in
september so hopefully they do but there
is a little bit of bad news in terms of
the m2 chip because
ming chi kuo recently earlier this month
said that he believes the redesigned
macbook air is on track for later this
year but it actually might use the same
m1 chip
which is extremely disappointing
and to me this makes no sense at all
because he is saying it's coming in the
fall that makes sense no mini led
unfortunately according to him but an m1
ship
that just does not make sense to me that
is just so disappointing and i
personally think he is wrong i
personally think the m1 chip is going to
stick around because the current macbook
air will probably still be on sale so
i'm hoping that happens and in terms of
the m1 m2 and m3 release cycle i believe
it's between a 1.5 to two year update
cycle so that means that it totally
makes sense for the m2 to be coming out
around the spring or the summer
so wwdc would make sense for the new m2
macbook pro and then another year and a
half or two years after that which could
mean that the m3 chip could come in the
fall of 2023
and that actually perfectly lines up to
ross young's leak of the 15 inch macbook
pro coming in 2023 because that's going
to be the next update so that would come
with the m3 chip at the end of 2023 so
everything kind of lines up there so
with that said with all those leaks
together i think the redesigned macbook
air is coming in the fall october or
november with the m2 chip with white
bezels a notch white keyboard just like
i showed you guys in these renders i
think it's going to be absolutely
beautiful and i think the people who are
saying that the notch is ugly they're
going to take that back as soon as they
see the real thing that apple's going to
release it's just going to look awesome
so with that said hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right over there and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]